foreign
and so I'd like to take this opportunity
to welcome all our guests to the uh
higher education study committee here in
in the house in the Senate and we do
have a agenda it's uh a short agenda but
it has three healthy topics on it and
um so I'd like to start out by just
welcoming everybody and to go around and
I think we all have introduced ourselves
so is you know we have Shannon Reed and
Mark Rubinstein Kathy provincher Nate
babitz right not voted bottage and I
think I get and Wayne Jones and uh
Maureen
um Mooney is a representative that's
been placed on this committee this is
her first trip on the higher education
study committee Oliver Ford uh and
beside me of Senator Ruth Ward who's
chair of Senate education House
Education Senate
and representative who's been a previous
uh chair of education and and and
there's Dave luno down at Dan from
Hopkinton
morning Senator we are just starting
you're welcome to sit wherever you may
please
Roblox
okay
so we're just starting out here
and we have an agenda I'd like to ask
first is there any other item that folks
on the study committee would like to
discuss underneath other uh if so let's
just amend it right now or accept the
agenda as printed
so we will do that we'll just accept the
agenda as printed and we're going to
jump right into the uh first item
underneath uh our newer business here
today and I'd like to welcome Nate uh
potich to our committee he's Provost at
Plymouth State University and I had the
pleasure as a trustee with the
university system to listen to a
presentation conducted by Nate
several months ago now and really
interesting and I think it's important
that we understand what their what we're
doing in terms of academics out in the
schools Plymouth State and Keene State
College King and and UNH as well and so
Nate's been invited here today to take
us through what is transpiring here at
Plymouth state in terms of high impact
practices so welcome Nate
thank you thank you so my hope today is
to sort of simplify things while uh
giving you some insight into what we're
doing so there's a bit of jargon but I
will do my best to minimize so I'm going
to talk about high impact educational
practices which have become known as
hips the acronym a bit tedious but
um and a little bit of history in a
background and I'll explain why I think
they matter and then I'll talk a bit
about some of the ways that we in the
usnh system engage in these high impact
educational practices So This Acronym
hip came into regular use about 15 20
years ago in 2008 a guy named George
published this book called high
impact educational practices and who has
access to them and why they matter and
it was the first sort of sustained look
at you know different kinds of teaching
methodologies focusing specifically on
this set of practices which I'll talk
about and I think it really was it was
an effort to say okay we know the
lecture model where the professor stands
in front of the classroom and he or she
shares their wisdom and everyone takes
notes and then hopefully on the day of
the exam they spit it out right and get
an A that worked well for all of us I
think um but I do think we recognize and
research has shown that there are other
ways of learning that can be really
valuable and I think high impact
practice has fallen to that that
category so
um the there were sort of 10 high impact
practices that he identified arbitrarily
and the lists have been modified I'm
going to talk today about six of them
because those six are tied to a survey
called the national survey of student
engagement which over the years millions
of students have engaged in at thousands
of universities and it really is a
survey about this kind of learning high
impact practice learning so the
categories that I'm going to sort of
refer to the examples of I impact
practice are things like Service
Learning so they ask students about how
many of your courses have included
community-based project or service
learning where you're getting out there
and providing service to a community or
a group so that's one high impact
practice learning communities now I
don't know if how familiar you are but
it's become more and more common to put
groups of students together both inside
and outside the classroom
because we all know that a lot of
learning happens outside of the
classroom so for example our nursing
students
if they elect to they can live on a
floor of one of our dorms where all the
nursing students share you know live
together and we know from research that
though that learning happens in that
context as well as in the classroom
another high impact practice which
you're familiar with research with
faculty
this is one of those things where
one-on-one time or small group time with
the faculty member focusing on serious
research the lasting impact of that is
tremendous
internships and field experience getting
out of the campus getting off campus
getting into communities and working you
know that's something our students need
to do and we know that Hands-On applied
work is a powerful educator great way to
learn another high impact practice study
abroad getting out of your comfort zone
and getting out of your country and
seeing how the rest of the world works
for better and For Worse
and uh at uh the presentation in April
the Board of Trustees uh Provost Jones
talked about study abroad they have an
extensive and diverse really powerful
study abroad programs at UNH which they
are generous enough to share with
Plymouth State University students so
it's been a partnership that's been good
for us and finally a big practices that
I'll talk about is a culminating senior
experience and what they mean by this is
does the seniors at your University at
the end of their experience think about
how their four years come together can
they walk out of the University with a
clear set of skills a vision you know
can they synthesize what they've learned
in a way that makes their college
experience meaningful
so those are examples of these high
impact practices
now why do they matter
um it's been like I said about 15 almost
20 years since this book was published
and there's three significant takeaways
that research has shown and again
there's tons of data on this
three things arise from engaging in
these high impact practices first of all
high impact practices improve retention
and graduation rates
students research has shown again that
students who participate in hips are
more likely to persist have higher gpas
than their peers and graduate on time
more likely to graduate within six years
than those students who don't who just
engage in traditional classroom learning
so that's one big Advantage retention
and graduation
the second thing and it shouldn't come
as a surprise students who engage in
high impact practices have clear career
advantages as they leave College
if you participate in these practices
it's a statistically significant
predictor of future career and early job
attainment so you know this is a
transferable set of skills you're
learning how to work while you're in
college so you leave and you're ready
you don't need to you know make mistakes
at three jobs before you figure out what
it means to be an adult and make a
living
um and I think the third significant
benefit that's been documented by
research and this one is is especially
important for me at Plymouth State and I
think Mark's team
the preparation gaps that students come
to college with you know we know that
students don't all come equally prepared
you know they don't all have the same
academic background same family
structure you know who if that's going
to be very diverse preparation coming
into the college Environ it makes I know
as a professor myself you have to teach
to all the students in the room that can
be immensely challenging high impact
practices close those preparation gaps
because they don't rely on academic
education alone high impact practice is
really leverage skills that students
often already have right do you know how
to work do you know how to work in teams
do you know how to synthesize do you
know how to figure things out with your
hands maybe instead of a book
so it's I think it's really interesting
this idea that these kinds of courses
these kinds of practices that we build
into our teaching actually serve
students that come to our colleges our
campuses less prepared
um you know these have become recognized
drivers of success and so in the usnh
system and all of our campuses we've had
to really ensure that our students won
they have these experiences and we've
been all very deliberate about that and
I'll talk about some ways that we've
been delivered about that and the second
thing isn't always the case we have to
gather data and make sure that what
we're doing is effective and how can we
improve it that's a constant for us
so if you look at the second page here
and one of the interesting and important
things it's nice to highlight I don't
always get to highlight successes in my
job but in this case I do
um it this this survey again the
national survey of student engagement
um 469 colleges participated last year
uh 1700 have since 2000 uh last year
over a quarter of a million students
responded to the survey over six and a
half million have over the years and if
you look at the message it's clear Kane
state Plymouth State and UNH Excel when
it comes to this kind of teaching
methodology these high impact practices
we're ahead of our peer institutions New
England public colleges and universities
and Carnegie class comparators
so I this is a real success and I think
it's important to note
we're three very different institutions
in the usnh system
who we serve what our mission is how we
articulate how we play to our strengths
those are very different universities
and what I find interesting is as
different as we are we are all strong in
this really important area in our own
different ways please
just adding one thing for contacts uh
those numbers if you compare ours to our
peer groups put us put you and H number
22 in the country of all research
universities in the country and put
Keane and Plymouth both in the top
quartile for their respective peer
groups so this is really a top
performing area for all of our campuses
it's applicable more broadly than that
the the way the survey is run not every
institution does it every year but every
institution will do it over a period of
three years uh and so that integrates
over the three years for the numbers I
gave
yeah
so it it's interesting and I what I
really and then what we talked about at
the board meeting I wanted to put some
some meat on this to give some examples
so it's not all theoretical so
um and Wayne talked about study abroad
and he had a presentation on it
um and James Bibi at Keane did a
presentation on student research and he
because we were a team during the
meeting three students came up and
talked about their work uh and how
they've worked with faculty members and
external entities an architect that was
an amazing presentation
to really change that have the intense
meaningful and after graduation powerful
educational experience and what I talked
about and what I will talk about today
is how we do it at Plymouth state
um our cluster model our cluster
learning model which you probably may
have heard about from president Burks is
really all about high impact practices
when Don came to Plymouth State eight
years ago now he looked at what we were
doing and said okay what do our students
need what are the students in North
Country and New Hampshire need and he
said we want them to graduate equipped
to get out there solve problems and make
a difference and what do we need to do
that well he'd been thinking about this
as a scientist researcher and academic
but also someone who's worked in
Industry he knows how to get things done
and he knows the tools that students
need so we put together this cluster
model that focuses on an applied
interdisciplinary project-based
education and that's really what Don's
vision is about and that's one of the
reasons I came to Plymouth state is very
powerful working you know students
working in teams to solve real world
problems and doing that in an
environment first in the classroom but
then outside the classroom in the Kim
Community making an impact in New
Hampshire so our whole curriculum from
the day that a student walks onto campus
they're going to take a course that fits
into this high impact model so all of
our freshmen take a course called
tackling a wicked problem
and literally the professor and the
students when the class starts don't
know what the problem will be
life doesn't you don't get to pick the
problems you have to solve in life so
one of the challenges in this course is
to figure out okay what problem are we
going to work on and the second thing is
it has to be a wicked problem not an
easy problem all the important
challenges that confront us are wicked
complicated complex not black or white
and so we want to have our students
thinking that way as early as possible
so tackling a wicked problem is
precisely that okay what are we going to
work on okay homelessness in North
Country that's a wicked problem there's
not an easy solution to it so the
faculty and the students will come up
with a project to see how they can begin
addressing they're not going to solve
the problem but start tackling it
working on it this kind of learning
happens in all majors all programs this
high impact engaged learning getting out
of the classroom Community Learning
um as a senior again one of those six
high impact practices is a Capstone a
senior experience that integrates all of
our seniors take what we call an in-cap
surprise surprise integrated Capstone to
make sure that they have a sense of the
breadth and the connections in their
education through their four years
so
um
the
other way that we do was we we do these
cluster projects they're called and it's
one of the most powerful examples and I
think this is maybe why uh
representative Ladd found this in
compelling story uh back in Durham and
when was it when I did the presentation
on the Gorham project or my students did
I didn't was that the fall October
October so we had a bunch of students
working with one of our business
professors Chantal forged and she knew
that she heard of this the Gorham paper
mill up outside of Berlin had been
purchased by a wealthy Mass a New Yorker
who Manhattan Knight who was trying to
figure out what to do with it uh
producing a little bit of paper but
basically this huge plot of land not
really put to good use didn't know what
to do with it our students went up there
as a group as a Consulting team and
worked with Town Citizens Business
people surveyed the community worked
with this owner from New York to come up
with four different business models of
how you could leverage that space that
land so you know having to do with a
farm to table possibility or an outdoor
adventure space or some I think the farm
to table had a b feature so Bunches of a
manufacturing plan which I think is
ultimately what the owner went with
working with the Canadian company so
this is a prime example of our students
being sent out into the real world to
solve a problem that does not have a
predetermined answer
what I've put in front of you this is a
another version instead of the Gorham
paper mill project which I'm I'm happy
to share you their 100 and something
page Consulting report if you're
interested that they provided the owner
but what I have today is pardon me if
you go to
the Plymouth creative pfu PSU
student-run marketing design agency this
is another again this is a course
students get credit for this and it's a
course run by two business professors
and an Arts Professor who specializes in
graphic design and essentially what the
course is
is a marketing and advertising and
design agency called Plymouth creative
and this has been going now for a couple
of years
um and it's had a tremendous impact uh
these professors they get out there in
the community they do various kinds of
work it's completely experiential it's
engaged with the community so if you go
to the next page you see about 15 to 20
students 25 students a semester and if
you scroll through to this funny looking
page to the services offered
you can see what they offer to local
business people as their services so you
want to do graphic design work or social
media work we have a one of the partners
in town uh peppercorn Market which I'm a
big fan of on Main Street there they
were inept at social media so they
really needed our students to do among
other things a social media campaign for
them which is now excellent web
development market research so again for
the Gorham paper mill project the
students surveyed the community and
figured out what do people want how can
we use this piece of land
uh event planning and branding and
campaign development so
they've worked now with um there's a
full list of Partners here but it's very
impressive
um Gunstock ski resort Owl's Nest
Waterville Valley we have a car
um for the new New Hampshire Electric
Co-op that drives around campus a
plug-in car that's wrapped in a design
done by these students local charity
Franconia Inn and then again my favorite
this peppercorn Market which they've
done tremendous work with they
completely closed this Market down
rebuilt it rebranded it found extra
funding in fact which surprised me I
didn't know they'd been involved in that
and they reopened about a month ago they
had a grand reopening and they've been
knocking it out of the park with the
help of our students they've done a
great job
so if you look at the testimonials you
know we have a full list of Partners
here this is an amazing thing this is a
free service that we provide to people
who might not have the resources like
peppercorn Market they don't have the
money to go hire a Tony firm to help
them with their marketing campaign our
students have done tremendous work for
them and they've seen real value and
return on this and of course if you go
to the next page of testimonials it's
our students
they're working they're out there in the
world making a difference figuring out
how to how to leverage their education
and then the last two pages there's a
full list of Our Community Partners
which will continue to grow
um and it's just been it's really
rewarding uh watching these students do
this and the impact on our local
businesses they're working with Tenney
Mountain uh it was an ambitious
expansion efforts with a mass investor
so there's tons of opportunity and I
just really admire and then I had to my
faculty colleagues uh Pam Anderson
Denise Hutchins and George botanico I
wanted to celebrate their creativity and
Entrepreneurship so this is just a quick
snapshot of what you're doing
these high impact practices are not new
to any of us at any of our institutions
we've served our communities the North
Country New Hampshire at PSU we've been
doing this for 150 years UT prosum that
I may serve that's our motto and that's
one of the cores of this sort of
educational philosophy and the cluster
learning model and these high impact
practices are way of moving that Vision
forward so I've overstayed my welcome
talk too much I will be quiet now and
but I think it's important that you see
how we're thinking how we're
collaborating working to serve our
students and what they need and
ultimately our communities in the state
of New Hampshire so thank you
thank you very much Nate that's a
wonderful overview of the program and I
just recall when the trustees were
provided this information we talked
about how a logo can really impact
um the university system and I'm sure
Wayne that UNH went through a lot of
this When developing the new logo you
have here now or I hope they did so what
I'd like to do is I'd like to open this
up to questions from the committee at
this time if folks have questions to ask
of
Nate
represent uh Senator oh thank you my son
is a graduate of Plymouth State Plymouth
State University it I think
he gave it the basic five
because his parents were paid the bills
but he stood very well I I like I like a
couple of things that that you're doing
I did meet with the president on a
couple of occasions actually I saw him
down here
uh it clicked a couple of weeks ago that
I enjoy his uh
his vision
I think he is a Visionary uh it
certainly uh out of the ordinary of what
I would call the classic academic
College president there are two things
that impressed me uh that uh I I think
will serve the university well as you
move forward
the service experience
The Faculty instruction the integration
with the faculty I've been a faculty
member at Saint anselves prologue type
uh a bit of the post-secondary education
for most of my adult life
but I think the fact that that there's
an integration situation with the
faculty gives the student a a much
better opportunity to not only learn but
to progress
and
without that I I I think we we're losing
something so
very very interested in that the um
the wrap-up course
when I was at UNH we had La 51 which was
uh just like what you're uh what you're
articulating
it was a course that that brought music
brought aren't
but the community part brought
everything together and I was I was uh
really uh
it's excited by the course the the
problem is it only lasted one semester
I mean those things should last
throughout your entire college
experience
um I would like to see what your
attrition rate is based on this this
formula
and what it was Prior what it what it is
what it is now
uh because getting a student is
difficult I was director of admissions I
would tell you but that Southern New
Hampshire University getting him as one
thing retaining of something else if all
of these things are in play you should
have a better success rate in terms of
rotating kits and if you're retaining
kids
their their desire to stay here is
probably intensified because we want
them to stay in New Hampshire oh I I'd
really like to see some data
on the results of this now he's been
he's been there eight years yeah eight
years now so he's probably had one real
graduating class because it takes six
years right so he's had one graduating
class
what's the attrition rate what's this
what's the success with the preliminary
success rate in terms of a their ability
to get a job opportunity but secondarily
did they stay here in New Hampshire
was there enough done in terms of
helping them to get a good situation in
New Hampshire and rotating the New
Hampshire uh that's that's a problem
that we have witnessed or I've witnessed
we see an outward migration rate of of
young kids but with these in place they
should they should make a significant
impact on our ability to retain students
uh and
the the exciting things that are being
created and I don't want to go out
because others want to speak but the
exciting
the exciting situation that's being
created in Via Chester with deed cabin
I I do a few things with with the deed
cable
but that opportunity
in the in the real world to do really
good things
should right across the board you know
these kinds of things remaining in New
Hampshire are being created retaining
not only being retained here but
expanding here should create opportunity
so two quick responses I don't want to
monopolize but we both said
simultaneously the data speaks for
itself so we know uh not just here I
mean again there's National Data on this
that students that engage in these
practices but you are right to say well
show me a Plymouth state that that's the
case and we can one of the challenges
for president Burks having said that is
this little thing happened a few years
into his time right and so the data's
been affected by that but we know that
even having said that that we were up by
about almost 10 percent from when he
arrived our retention rate has improved
closing in on 70 percent which compared
to our comparators is quite High you
know obviously it's it's not an R1
University it's not an ivy so we don't
that's not a relevant comparison but to
our comparators we've improved by almost
10 percent which is significant your
second point about keeping our students
where they belong well we serve we I
don't this semester 43 of our incoming
class are first generation students from
New Hampshire that's a significant
impact those are students you know that
this is we're making a difference we are
the opportunity for them and one of the
reasons we're so committed to this kind
of work getting students out of the
classroom into the community is so that
they're connected so that they have
those connections so I just shook hands
like you did at commencement with kids
who I've met who've engaged in these
things Gorham paper mill they're going
back to their communities you know who
did they think they thanked Plymouth
State and their parents and the White
Mountains who inspire me every day to
serve the state of New Hampshire I mean
I had a student say that to me it's so I
do think
um tracking the data on employment is
something we also work on so we can
report on that as well if
if I could just add one additional data
point for you you know at UNH we pay
very close attention to if a student
does an internship or a community
engagement exercise like this and they
come from out of state they are twice as
likely to stay in the state and work in
the state sixty percent of the students
that do an internship or community
service project in the state when they
cost additional tuition money in the
part of the student or how are they paid
for
um no the students never pay more our
students can't and we don't want them to
that's not this is supposed to be
value-added for everyone involved so we
go out of our way institutionally we
have to expend labor and make the
connections and and make sure that all
the legal bases are covered risk
management issues are dealt with right
if we're sending our students out we
have to be responsible to those things
so it's not a free by any means but it's
worth it to us and to our students the
value added
just put a few more numbers on it I the
biggest investment we make is actually
creating the structures that bring us
One-Stop shop for companies to come to
us and for communities to come to us
with these challenges so at UNH we have
2 700 New Hampshire companies
that are working with our career and
professional success office many of them
it's paid many of them it's not it's
it's a mix of whether they pay the
student or not and we navigate that
space the key is to give them a One-Stop
shop I need help I would like to engage
with students you know can you put me in
touch with the right Department with the
right faculty member with the right
program and that's that's where we make
actually uh
Senator Del Sandro asked my question I
was going to happen but you just
prompted another one with the success
that you've had of having students stay
in the state I would suggest that you
meet with our budget committee
and bring those stories to the budget
committee
because particularly as you begin to
look at the whole issue of the Workforce
Development within the state Kathy can
you respond to that the
um thank you for the question and
actually our budget request
was specifically targeted for Plymouth
and Keene to stand up more opportunities
for internship and Community engagement
UNH invested its own dollars half a
dozen years ago and has built the
infrastructure they have more internship
opportunities at UNH than they have
students
that will or can take them but it takes
investment for Plymouth and Keen
to to stand up that engine if you will
and to work with business partners right
there's has to be an infrastructure
there so that was a big part of our
budget request
this is the follow-up it would seem to
me that if you have I'm not sure whether
you had any students come before the
budget committee to talk about their
experience because I think that's
important as well as the businesses that
they've been working with so that so
that our legislature here begins to
understand not just from a theoretical
standpoint
or an esoteric standpoint but a
practical standpoint of how these hip
programs are in fact engaging students
and then staying in the state because
that's obviously is we know it's a huge
issue here and we need to understand
that from a legislative standpoint of
what the return on investment is as we
begin to deal with these programs
are you awake
was in the legislature right now
Workforce housing
how's that Wicked program impacting
these students which are coming out of
unh Plymouth State Keene State and the
community college system in terms of
finding housing
yes it's huge everywhere I mean I and I
think it's interesting so yes it's a big
problem we know that and I think one of
the interesting things is the different
ways that within the system we're trying
to to address it to or to support and
addressing it so what you were saying
yeah it's also a challenge it's an
enormous challenge it's an enormous
challenge for current students that want
to do an internship with a company in
the North country and can't because they
don't have a place to stay or they're
trying to do something in Manchester
they prefer to live in Manchester while
they're finishing their degree in in
Durham the other place where we have an
enormous challenge is recruiting
students in at The Graduate level these
are professional Masters MBA uh Masters
in health care those students want to
come to the state they want to get this
higher education
um but when they come they can't afford
to live here certainly within some of
those regions so the same thing that our
companies are seeing the universities
are seeing as well and we're trying to
find new ways to address it and I would
say it's heightened where we are in
Plymouth and not that it's not difficult
where I've had tremendous difficulty
recruiting faculty and staff again the
students have their own set of issues
with that but my ability to bring top
quality people to Plymouth State when I
have such limited housing opportunities
for them that are affordable and
accessible and close to campus that's
been a huge challenge for us
our some partnership with the community
college system
um we have a new robotics program that
was one of the visions of President
Burks uh and I've just hired a new
leader of the program he's joining us
he's trying to find a place to live one
of his challenges uh but the robotics
program is a perfect example of again
Don's vision of we don't want
straightforward one program departments
that's not how we work we don't have
departments but we have these clusters
and the robotics program integrates game
design you know manufacturing and
Robotics computer science graphic all
the other elements that go into we also
have a game design program which
integrates computer science and Robotics
and storytelling right all so these
kinds of programs they're tremendously
powerful and we know that it's part so
we're building programs to address those
things
um what's interesting about it is that
the way that AI AI computer science data
science data analytics and Robotics
there's a whole Spectrum where they can
there those need to be leveraged and
applied so the work you're doing in the
community college system is incredibly
important important we need people who
can go in and and do what needs to be
done at a very applied level on you know
in uh Manufacturing Systems for example
That's essential and then okay so what's
the next step what about programming in
a manufacturing facility what about
building robots implicating what about
designing what about the programming
that goes behind that work and that
scales up so I think there's a role for
the community colleges places like
Plymouth State and then R1 universities
they're doing The Cutting Edge so I
think there's multiple answers to the
question that you ask and the answers
are going to come from all of us in
different ways so the follow-up on that
Rick and thanks for for uh for talking
about this and
um it reminds me of the conversation I
had with Mark a couple years ago too
when I think we were over on the nhci
campus and you said what can what can
our students be doing to help you in the
legislature so so some of the wicked
problems that that that you know we
confront here uh obviously policy
related and we're using um
decades-old tools to try to solve those
like you know Excel spreadsheets and
things like that to try to model what
this means and um and an example that I
think you know several of us here
probably familiar with is school funding
and um Rick you and I spent spent a ton
of really good valuable time but but
we're basically using you know linear
models on you know what does this mean
for um for districts and the number of
of English language Learners or free and
reduced price lunch kids and stuff like
that but there's so many other factors
that come into play now too and um and
you know um
and I think this is one of the things
Mark and I talked about I mean you know
school funding policy translates right
down into tax balls and I know that can
be a bad word around here but you know
but that's that's State funding so so
homeowners that own property less than
five hundred thousand dollars or
homeowners that own property more than
two million dollars or homeowners that
own property manufactured housing or or
living in apartments and we have that
data now it's a massive data set yep but
I think it's probably beyond the
capacity of of Rick and I to to to model
model the effects
um on that and and probably would be
asking too much of the budget office to
um
are some of these things which and you
know I think in the state of New
Hampshire public school funding has been
the wicked problem that we have not been
able to solve
um and part of that is Will to solve it
but Paul part of it is how to solve it
and um and you know and you know and and
I think this is an area where where
clearly as as as as people who live here
in New Hampshire we're all interested
people who have had kids grow up in New
Hampshire we're all interested and then
obviously from a from a um from a
business side you know the community
colleges and the and the university
system certainly have an interest in
kids succeeding
um in in K-12
um and uh making sure that the uh the
the 13 000 kids in Manchester are having
the same opportunities of success as the
Thousand kids at Hopkins I mean you know
I I I'm used with Patty Cornell was
around the table here she knows that I
always use Manchester sometimes she
winces a little bit
um but uh but you know New Hampshire has
more homeless kids than Hopkinton has
kids in the in the in the K-12 system so
you know how do you solve that Wicked
problem and uh to make sure that these
kits have the have the same
opportunities as the other students in
Manchester and the other students in
Hanover and Hopkinton and um
and and when I'm talking about
opportunities too I'm talking about
opportunities for Success so the average
student in Manchester performs at the
fourth percentile Statewide
so 96 percent of students in New
Hampshire perform better than the
average student in Manchester
so you know you know that that's an
opportunity not just for the for the you
know for the kids to I mean you know a
fourth percentile outcome is a great you
know isn't a strong outcome but
um even though we have you know strong
outcomes Statewide in New Hampshire but
uh but you know what does this mean for
our economy what does this mean for the
the
um you know you know this type of
learning model
um uh if uh if if if if we can you know
move the needle in some of these places
by look by solving
that Wicked problem then it starts to
help solve a lot of other Wicked
problems
a huge one there representative but you
know there is another Wicked problem
that I heard the senator to my left
speak to at the finance committee the
other day and that's Civics education K
through 12. and I don't know where the
Senate is on that right now Lou whether
you've dropped it from two to one
million dollars but
um it's a wicked problem it needs
resolution whether we're going to come
up with what I think the senator wants
to see is a textbook and this
representative wants to see the same
thing not we're kind of old-fashioned
but uh there needs to be something in
front of the student but how how could
we utilize these programs that you have
that you're talking about
and rather than are having to contract
some service out to somebody out in
Arizona to write our Civics program
could we not be using what what we have
on board within various departments uh
as part of this this
Wicked problem hip type programming
to get to that end point we want
without
with the the means that we have to pay
for it I
I you might want to talk more about that
Lou but I think we have to really talk
about how we're going to develop the
Civics K through 12 program right that
we drastically need in the state of New
Hampshire
well it's not there's certainly no
question that we share at the same view
uh
K-12 is is where the action should be
but let me uh refer representative
talked about Manchester I served on the
Manchester school board for 10 years
Committee of the Baychester school board
and I I have a I have a district where I
have eight minority schools eight
minority schools I I guess in the rest
of the state they probably had eight
minority schools district
what is that what does that mean that
means blacks and Hispanics represent
more than 50 percent of the enrollment
that's a challenge both for the district
for what's beyond the district
I was looking at truancy rates yesterday
uh and I was looking at attendance rates
we have the oldest public high school in
the state of New Hampshire beatchester
High School Central the attendance rate
78 percent
graduation rate at Manchester High
School West which has 737 students my
children all went to West my wife went
to West my kids went through the BHS
assistant K through 12.
has a graduation rate of 60 percent
60 percent
the highest graduation rate in the city
is at Memorial I think it's 80 percent a
little bit higher than 80 percent so
we're talking about the the things that
are happening at the post-secondary
level you're right what about K-12 and
I've been around here for a long time I
was I was on the committee of conference
on the first education funding piece of
if if we don't address that situation
uh where are the youngsters that we're
we're we're hoping for them our future
where are they where are they going to
go and how are they going to get there
how are they going to get there that's
that's that's my concern it's Civics I
taught Civics I say this all the time
one of my Civic students was a secretary
of state August serving secretary of
state in the United States I had him at
the ninth grade
I had the Speaker of the House in the
ninth grade I had Alex Ray in the ninth
grade pretty successful people
all right what do you think of it uh
I was teaching Civics in those days
and it meant something because of the
involvement of of these people I think
that's where we have to we have to get a
grasp of that I
I know how important it is we had a
chance a number of years ago I would say
probably in
1978-1980 when August delivered a
formula that phobia that would have
solved that problem
it would have solved that problem it was
vetoed by the governor
it was vetoed by the governor and as a
result of that we've gone this way with
education ever since
we're in court right now
we may lose that suit I think it's more
likely to lose it than that but what's
going to happen if you lose it they turn
it back to the lead selection so here we
are
um
I like what's happening at the
post-secondary level but the base
it is like where it's at the base is
how do we how do we face face up to that
and how does this post-secondary play a
role in helping us you know it's a part
of early school we we used to have
keyed state
students come and do their practical at
partner voting I don't know if we'd have
that any any more but we need that kind
of we need that kind of help we need
that kind of integration and and uh how
what better social experience is there
than to come to a place like Manchester
which which is beatchester is an urban
center it's not the old VHS that I came
to you know 50 something years ago when
I was teaching high school at Bishop
Bradley high school it's a different
worlds though
uh we we have social workers in all of
our River schools
social workers I mean these are the
Deeds that have that are being
manifested and
you know extend that
to the post-secondary level where these
kids where are these kids going to end
up they don't go to they don't go to
plymouth's key UNH they don't go to the
Community College I don't know where
they're going
but they're certainly not being prepared
properly to go any place okay that's
dangerous and that's what we that's what
we face with all the glaring
opportunities that are available talk
about cabin cable tells me he needs 4
000 workers
he could Hire 4 000 people
he needs 200 Engineers graduated
the University of New Hampshire our
engineering school one of the best in
the country
are those Engineers gravitating you know
to to Manchester the other problem is
exists but but I think K-12 and I know
a gentleman on this stage have spent a
lifetime working on it well I've spent a
lifetime working on I've been involved
in it teaching and I still live in the
same house 51 years later all right
bought it for a very big resistance I I
tell people my mortgage was 148 a month
and I had trouble making it
because I was working at a school and I
was getting 5 000 bucks a year as my
salary so
the problem space is the problem that
faces us they looked at the numbers
30 000 free breakfasts in beer Chester
30 000 free breakfasts
seventy thousand free and reduced price
lurches does that tell you how poor uh
the city has the city is would you have
that kind of that kind of a situation 78
attendance rate highest at interest
rates are the the quality areas of
Beatrice so that I we got to start there
we've got to start there and that's
that's a whole Dental situation that's
got that's got to chase we gotta we
gotta excite people about the about how
meaningful it is how meaningful it is
and how important it is
uh it's I think as I say it starts K
through 12 and then it goes over and uh
we can do a lot at the post-secondary
level I think a lot has been done but
indeed the Corpus keeps shrieking
you get fewer graduates yeah if you were
numbers
I and I think uh the kids that that
you're getting if there are kids so need
need more help they just they just need
more help so maybe Senator we can have a
response from the universities but I
also like to hear you know maybe some
input on where the senator is coming
from in terms of the community college
system so Wayne why don't you go first
and then uh and then the chancellor sure
happy to so so first of all I think a
key aspect of all of this is is the
partnership and how are we working
together I'm delighted that you know we
are in your schools you have teachers
from Keene and Plymouth and and UNH uh
in Manchester schools literally the
president and I and our team was over at
uh one of the minority serving schools
on the on the east side I don't remember
the name of the school off the top of my
head last week
um as part of our Embrace New Hampshire
tour
um in general and I'll go back to uh
representative luno's comment earlier
just like we have a mechanism in place
where companies can come to us and say
we have a wicked problem do you have a
student a team that could work on this
whether that be marketing or analytics
or AI that exists for communities as
well and we do work with communities on
everything from marketing to how do they
Implement new strategies some of those
are very successful for example in
Manchester we just got the a major NSF
award several million dollars to work on
how do you elevate inner city schools
and how do you create new Partnerships
that link to social work programs as
well as all those other things that you
need I think we have to see this more as
as a partnership and we'd love to hear
you know where would a team of students
doing a Capstone project or where would
a graduate student and a faculty member
working with a couple of others be able
to provide new insights that would be
helpful from data analytics or or other
so when you hear about those things
we're very interested we're doing many
of them but we could do more and so I
would say if you hear about them please
ask and that includes K-12 I mean we
have we have certified teacher programs
at Keenan Plymouth that have the
expertise to build K-12 commit uh
curricula and we should be taking
advantage of that and we do everything
we can
we work up in the north country and and
different areas where we're finding
Partnerships and communities in need but
yeah there's there's tons of need and
more than we can serve so we need to
know we're trying to develop capacity
where this is we're meeting tomorrow we
have a six hour Provost retreat tomorrow
and one of our Central focuses is
education so this is top on our radar
sorry Senator just it was Gossler Park
that was where we went gospel Park was
where the oldest radio School of the
city it's adult as you can see
but with some great leadership and a
number of unh alumni that were there
working and we had our faculty there was
it's equated building it's just the
physical properties I I visit every
school in my district every year
and uh Joshua Park as I said oldest
oldest grade of school in in the city
and um the the administrator does a very
good job she's committed yes it is
amazing given the task
the task adhered
the amazing thing is these schools which
we
give that terminology to dump we have
one in woodswell as well and the
teachers and the staff really oftentimes
take offense with that due to the fact
they're really doing a great job with
the facilities that they have and and
mastering how to work in that but you're
absolutely correct those places are not
fit to be teaching in today
Chancellor do you can you add something
from the community college perspective
in regard to where we're going with this
conversation this is an important
conversation
well I'll try yeah I'm I'm reluctant to
have her disagree with Senator
D'Alessandro but I'm going to take a
moment when you say it starts with k
through 12 and I would offer that it
actually starts with Early Childhood
before we get to K
and I think that's one of the objectives
that we're trying to make provide more
capacity for high quality early
childhood education and child care which
is another Catalyst like Workforce
housing that if we can if we can break
that Log Jam if we can create that
capacity and not simply capacity for
where children can be while their
parents are working but real
foundational education that starts them
off on better footing that's part of the
solution
um the I've been in the legis with the
legislature a number of times where I've
referenced the free and reduced lunch
data come back to the point that not
only is it still more than one in five
students across New Hampshire more than
40 percent in Manchester but it's not
just a reflection of the students it's a
reflection of the parents of this
generation of school-aged children in
their circumstances in this economy in
this labor market so can we be doing
more simultaneously for that generation
nation of working adults to give them
on-ramps into the workforce at levels
that will be more consistent with what
the future of the state's calling for
um
the the other point that I'd like to
reference and it ties the two pieces of
this conversation together we started a
discussion about high impact practices
in post-secondary
going back to the need for better civic
education maybe the best civic education
is high impact finding ways to actually
engage students if there's a state in
this country that can actually
demonstrate what a citizen is
responsible for what being part of a
community means it's New Hampshire and
I'm wondering if there's not a way that
we can develop not just textbooks but
but learning experiences that really
engage students otherwise to find people
who are willing to sit in these chairs
over the next 10 20 30 40 years is going
to be harder but for them to understand
why you do what you do and what it means
to this state I think there's a real
opportunity so I think this conversation
that we started with with high impact
practices
ought to be tied back to the civic
education conversation for K-12
thank you we have several items on the
docket here for today and maybe we ought
to take a break here this is a topic
which you know that I'm glad we had the
discussion it there it we can't just
drop it but we have uh a number four on
our doc here Dr Wayne Jones
um
from the University system uh University
of New Hampshire are talking about
alternative Pathways to the bachelor's
degree and and it's just not the
bachelor's degree one of the issues
which we're dealing with is trying to
ensure that more students are coming out
of uh K through 12 with industry
recognized credentials and
um that's that basic hard skill that's
going to give them that and conform with
what the industries requesting as being
that standard and I'm curious to know
Wayne is is that something too that's
being emphasized at at your level as
well I know that we have
it going on our CTE centers and in
conjunction with the community college
system but I'm curious to know what
we're doing with that but I also gave
you that article to try to respond to so
why don't you go ahead with your
presentation and we won't throw more at
you
more questions are always welcome uh and
and I appreciated the you know sending
those the the articles that you did
represented the the you know does
college take four years is a college
degree worth it do we need general
education these are actually higher ed
challenges that are being discussed
Nationwide right now in fact literally I
I almost grabbed it but it didn't fit in
my briefcase conveniently The Chronicle
of Higher Education came out this month
and the cover is about is general
education really worth it or is it
broken
um I think to to provide a little bit of
background in context first and then I'm
going to address those questions and of
course any other questions you want
let's just take a step back and look at
the history of higher education that
puts us where we are today you know
everyone higher education is as it looks
today has its basis back in the 1700s
and even as late as the 1900s and 1950
it looked very similar the difference
was it was really targeted at Elite
Institute Elite institutions it was
targeted Elite the belief was that only
about 10 percent of students would get a
college degree uh that changed after
World War II and the GI bill
massification of higher education uh
unreal universities grew up all over the
place small colleges became parts of
State systems uh we went big in the 60s
it shifted again and the shift in the
60s was away from What was seen as
providing that Elite Education for
everyone to professionalizing how do we
make sure that we have professional
schools professional engineering degrees
got new levels of of growth Health Care
degrees education schools of Education
all that professionalization came in
uh if you fast forward a little bit uh
you you moved to uh into the 90s and
into 2000 2010 what you see is now
everybody wants the degree you go from
20 of students applying for a college
degree to 50 60 and as a result you get
new players in the market you get
privates online coming in
after 2015 and now after the pandemic it
looks much different it looks different
for a couple of reasons one declining
High School graduation rates
particularly in the Northeast more
importantly culturally students are
saying hey I can do things differently
uh in a recent in a recent poll that was
quoted in this article it talked about
how only 41 percent of high school
seniors said it was very likely that
they were going to go to college
60 percent of those students said that
their most likely path was to start
their own business and become an
entrepreneur fifty percent said they
were going to become social influencers
I'm not commenting on those but the
point is the culture has shifted in what
the students think they want we're also
at a time where many fewer students are
going right into college they're taking
Gap years funded by their parents in
some cases Senator comment that uh
jokingly on that earlier
um it's a different environment in that
space we also have the challenge that
employment has gone from you know in the
70s in in 2007 2008 employment
unemployment was high many places States
turned on requirements for bachelor's
degrees because they needed to thin out
their pools because everybody was
applying for these jobs now they're
going the other way now they're turning
them off unemployment is too low maybe
we don't need a bachelor's degree for
you to be able to work in the motor pool
or for you to be able to work in other
aspects
universities today are trying to adapt
to that environment at the core of that
I think is what I'll call integration
for life there's a recognition that
universities don't just provide content
for 18 to 24 year olds in that period
right after high school in fact we
should be providing support for
individuals throughout their lives and
we should be providing uh the the
content and that expertise in a manner
that is flexible I would say there's
four key aspects of what higher
education is trying to drive today and
I'm I'm proud to say that all of the
campuses in the community in usnh and
our partners in the community college
system are doing the same thing we're
trying to create more flexible degree
pathways
do you need a four-year degree no you
can get your degree in three years six
percent of students last year at UNH
graduated in three years
15 of students could have chose not to
they chose to finish and to get more
credits than they needed they need 120
credits to graduate the average at UNH
is like 138. we're not requiring it
they're choosing it because they wanted
to do double majors and triple majors
um Partnerships with employers is
absolutely key
all disciplines in the University system
go through disciplinary accreditation
which is highly rigorous every five
years we get reviewed by our peers
across the country saying are we
teaching the right things are they
lining up with what is needed nationally
um that's not enough because employers
have specific needs and different
aspects they've emphasized soft skills
much more the work in high impact I'm
learning that that my colleague just
spoke about is absolutely critical to
that they're working in teams they're
working on interdisciplinary problems
it's not just about being an engineer
you have to know how to work with the
the business professional with the
marketing and design person and the
communications person to solve a problem
they're much more interdisciplinary
interdisciplinary education is is where
it's at you see that we have many more
students it was amazing at commencement
two weeks ago to listen all the students
walking across with double major this
and double major that at UNH we just
shifted our graduation instead of doing
the monster ceremony in uh in the
football stadium which many of you have
been to uh we now do it by college a
more intimate environment and yet many
of the students said well I'm getting a
degree from Paul College for business
and the College of liberal arts
can I go twice do I have to go twice
um that interdisciplinarity also shows
up in they want to provide different
ways of representing the skills they've
learned they want to be an engineer but
they want to have a language as well or
they want to get their degree in
business but they'd like to have music
as part of their degree
and now the university is is challenged
with how do we curate that how do we
help the students recognize that there's
connections maybe let them develop those
connections and then curate that a
couple ways of doing that obviously the
registrars are all over that but Micro
credentials micro certifications are
something that about five years ago the
system embraced uh aggressively and can
the valley who leads our extension
program in every corner of the state now
has literally a hundred different micro
Prudential
programs that students can take
um but anyone in the state could take
you don't have to get a degree you can
take a certificate or a weekend Workshop
or put together two courses to make your
own micro credential that demonstrates a
certain skill set
that's where higher education is going
today those are the types of things that
we're working through and we're
certainly not doing it in a vacuum
because even in addition to our our own
accreditation that we go through with
our peers
companies are key part of that every
college at UNH as well as my colleagues
at Keenan Plymouth have industrial
advisory boards that are part of that
leadership team that meet with the dean
meet with the department chair saying do
we have the right skills has it changed
in five years how did the pandemic
change it so those are the conversations
we're actively having those were touched
on in these articles very very
appropriately
um I would say you know
there's lots and lots of evidence that
employers uh are struggling as well not
just because of the the demand and the
the low unemployment rate but also
because today's students
have taken what happened naturally and
culturally where you got a job at I
remember I got an internship at IBM When
I Was An undergraduate I was told oh
you're set you're going to work for them
for 40 years
well that culture shifted but students
today are taking it further employers
today report back that they're seeing
that students want to take their first
job and only stay there for a year or
two and then take a jump and maybe take
a six-month gap between jobs before they
go to the next job
that's one of the reasons we see some
employers creating their own training
programs because if you go work for
Google and they train you on whatever
their their software or their process is
you can't then leave them and
necessarily translate that directly to
another job
we've had students I won't name the
student or the company but I will tell
you have a graduate student at UNH when
I brought there the student had been on
the books for 12 years to get their
degree what the heck are they doing I
dug into it right because I want to get
our time to degree as short as possible
the story was the individual was getting
a master's degree an opportunity to do
an internship in their last semester
went to the company to do the internship
and
never came back to finish their degree
all they had to do was write like 50
more pages and defend their thesis and
they would get their degree and they
weren't coming back for 12 years
and I'm like well let's go just go talk
to their manager their manager must want
them to get their degree they've been
promoting them they've been giving them
big raises and the response from the
manager was
if he gets his degree he'll probably
leave I don't want him to get his degree
I want to keep him too busy
and I think that's the mindset that
we're in that's what we're trying to
deal with and be flexible with as we
respond to the market
I think I'll stop my comments there and
dig into whatever aspect of that you
would most like to speak to
so much to that represent Myler yes what
role do students play in the development
of your programs
students play an active role in many of
the programs uh usually through advisory
boards every college has a student
Advisory board that works within many
departments do as well
um
I would say that we also find more
students participating in
the co-curricular activity so the high
impact practices every one of our
universities have both first year and
Capstone programs so for example if you
go to UNH and you go into the
engineering school we have the
Innovation Scholars Program
this is a program designed for students
day one first day as a freshman you can
get involved in a research project and
you helped to set what that project is
going to be our honors students do the
same thing they have a community service
project we don't tell them what they're
going to work on they tell us what they
want to work on they learn what skills
they need and it's our job to try and
help find that skill set to give them
support whether that be having an
entrepreneur in Residence that comes in
from the community or finding the right
types of training that the students need
so they're pretty actively involved
um and they're constantly pushing us
yeah I would just just to add to that
right
um there's two ways I mean obviously
students they vote with their feet so
they tell us right that's one of the
clearest ways we're we have to be
creative we have to take risks we have
to see what the market needs what New
Hampshire needs what trends are we need
to be smart about what we do but then we
have to listen to students
we're also doing student-centered
learning and everything we do so again
in at a very large scale thinking of the
programs we run but also how we teach
and what we do we try and we encourage
our colleagues to be constantly looking
at what do students respond to what were
the outcomes was it an effective
approach to that if not change it and I
think that kind of
it's constant Innovation there's an
element of risk we're going to try stuff
and see if it works but that's the only
way we're going to make progress is
there a downside to the university
system in terms of your revenues
when
we for example a Career Technical
Education Centers where the directors
are looking for skill in this technology
area and soft skills too in terms of how
to relate and communicate those
content areas that person possesses not
necessarily looking at a bachelor's
degree so when we're going in that Trend
possibly and probably realize how's that
going to impact the university system
are you going to have to change your
you're going to have to have this 120
hours
so the 120 hours for the degree is not
set by us it's set by the Department of
Education federally and that goes
through our creditor that being said
between
AP AP programs and others in high
schools the First Start program that
runs through the Community College many
students that come to us already have
you know 20 30 credits before they even
arrive on campus so that's why it's
relatively easy for students to graduate
three years they're just not used
choosing to do that
I think the
the more exciting piece is thinking
about how are students navigating
the micro credentialing space and that
skill space I really appreciate the CTC
so in the fall I went up and visited the
CTC at White Mountains High School I did
not remember the exact name White
Mountain House High School and they have
a wonderful manufacturing program and
their students are coming out with
skills that can directly take them into
a manufacturing job or with a little
more training at the community college
can take them into that technical path
but it also puts them on a road that
could take them into an engineering path
we have a gap between those two and so
is it a is it a revenue challenge for us
no I think it's a revenue opportunity we
should have our faculty and the
Community College faculty talking to the
ctcs about you don't have to get a
college degree you can go that other
path but you can if you want these are
options this part of that flexibility
that students are looking for today and
if they know about it in high school
then they can choose maybe they choose
to get a job right out of house high
school for a gap year and then they go
to the Community College and get a
couple of a couple of years under their
belt there while they're working and
maybe get an associate's degree and know
that oh a year later they could come
back and do a two-year degree and finish
up a bachelor's degree at Plymouth
um those are the conversations we have
to have more of but we can't afford to
stay in our silos where the CTC faculty
don't talk to the Community College
faculty and the Community College
faculty don't talk to the University
faculty we have to build that bridge to
make it work
representative Mooney thank you Mr
chairman and thank you all for being
here as I mentioned earlier my niece is
a proud graduate of Plymouth State
University and her brother went to UNH
Manchester so great to see you all here
my question is this I know in the
beginning stages of
um college and the end of high school
there are merge years for example
running start and the like is there
anything similar to that on the other
end for example you said somebody could
have finished up in three years decided
to stay for but could they somehow merge
their third and a half or fourth year
with their first year of a graduate
program and go it that way and if so is
that beneficial to you and how thank you
yeah I absolutely 4-1 programs three two
programs the idea that you can do your
bachelor's degree and your master's
degree at the same time is absolutely in
play across higher education including
all of our campuses even more
importantly I think it's another
opportunity for us to be able to build
new Bridges because we have students
that want to go to Keene because they
want to study
um
that any any maybe they want to study uh
social work uh at King as an
undergraduate but they want to get their
master's degree at UNH at the same time
I was trying to think of it through a
great program that was unique to them
too but
um it turns out that
that they can do right now we haven't
emphasized it and we haven't done the
hard work which we're trying to do now
through the retreat we're doing tomorrow
through the meetings we're doing with
the community colleges uh to try and
create more of those opportunities and
make them more public to the students so
that they know about them that's
something we have to do better yeah we
do it on our campuses yeah well we've
been doing it for a long time it's
value-added for the students you save at
least a semester and sometimes even a
Year's tuition and because some of the
credits overlap from the two degrees so
it's a great value process but right now
it's again to this so we are
trying to figure out as many ways as we
can to give movement
across our institutions that close these
gaps representative oh you see what Mark
do you want
okay I was going to ask Mark the
question of how many of your students
currently
uh go on are in the program where they
matriculate uh automatically into one of
the schools what percent that's sort of
getting into our discussion which is the
next bullet where we're looking at the
associates leading into the bachelor's
and but yes watch that's a good
would you turn on the mic please
sorry in a typical recent year somewhere
between 600 and 700 students will
transfer from the community college
and today at at the time that they start
there see if I may yes go ahead at the
time that they start their program as a
freshman do they
do they automatically get into that
program I mean do they how do they let
the institution know they want to
matriculate into one of the other uh
after they graduate or currently that's
an advising function for a student who
enrolls in the community college system
to identify that as a destination
ideally we'd be able to build that into
a platform that would allow a student to
map degree programs between the two
systems that doesn't currently exist but
we have articulation agreements and
pathway documents that describe for a
student that this series of courses
leads to that series of courses allowing
you to continue through to complete a
bachelor's degree so when they if
they're in that in that transition
period they're basically are taking what
their their cognitive programs or the
the basic programs so that when they
matriculate into the uh of the four-year
institution they basically are focused
in on their major is that how that is
that how that works it's probably going
to be a little bit more uh complex and
interwoven than that for instance a
student who is interested in a
bachelor's degree in accounting needs to
be taking some accounting courses
earlier than that a student who's
interested in the Health Sciences career
biological science career is going to be
taking anatomy and physiology in the
first two years so there are going to be
some prerequisite courses some courses
that align with the major as well as
some general education courses
you're welcome uh represent Ford has a
question but I I'd like to just sort of
like transition in number five on our
agenda this is a report on the status of
the implementation of measures that we
put in effect in 1530 HP 1530
establishing uh curricular transfer
Pathways between the community college
system in New Hampshire and the
university system New Hampshire ensuring
that
I can remember president Burks coming in
and saying that we're we're working
towards and anxious to accept uh our or
have a good working relationship with
white Mountain Community College where
those two years
though that they take at that level will
come in and count towards and we had the
30 Pat 30 different Pathways and all
that and maybe those credits count as
gen Ed but I'd like to really walk back
into this and I think representative
Ford has questions regarding this
um and and Wayne I'd ask you to speak to
that and also uh um Shannon and Mark
this is also we're working here on the
same topic we got about a half hour left
it seemed to have been discussing
traditional students throughout this
conversation here and I'm wondering if
we might also consider non-traditional
students any kind of segues into the
other issue of transferring credits
community college credits and so forth
so
who would ever like to take off with it
which are what's happening there sure um
Mark UK If I I'll take that and then
start and then let you continue so first
of all let's talk about non-traditional
that I I think that universities in
general across the country have been way
too focused on the 18 to 24 year old
that is not a growth Market that is a
that is a market that's probably going
to be steady but but but declining uh at
UNH we've actually said that our growth
is going to be at The Graduate level and
and the non-traditional non-credit and
micro credentialed Market that's where
our growth is going to be don't look for
UNH to be adding a lot more
undergraduates we're not going to we'd
like to keep the number that we have
right now I'd like to mix it with more
in-state students I'd like to increase
the the graduation rate which is already
really really good but that'll be the
space that we're going to work in in the
micro credential space in the non-credit
space in that non-traditional space and
I will acknowledge that the GSC under uh
Chancellor rubinstein's leadership uh
already has a very strong Market there
with students that are average age over
30 I believe
um
but in addition we have over 20
000 New Hampshire residents took part in
non-credit coursework at UNH last year
uh that number can't be overlooked
that's having an enormous impact and it
is generating Revenue that helps to
drive the university system so I think
it's very very important
coming back to HB 1530 and and touching
base on that we very much appreciated
the partnership and the and the
instigation of that uh as Chancellor
Rubenstein said we have many uh
articulation agreements in fact we have
three usnh campuses and seven ccsnh
campuses so we have 21 articulation
agreements for every degree program
nearly uh so we have hundreds and
hundreds of them what we need to do and
what this house bill 1530 is going to
help us to do is to create some
signature Pathways that will work for
all seven community colleges if possible
and all three system campuses
what we've done is we've set out to do
that through a really good partnership
uh Leslie um
Barber and Chancellor rubenstein's
office and Kate ziemer in my office are
leading the charge working between the
two systems to look at all of the
different degree Pathways of the 600
students that Chancellor Rubenstein
referred to the vast majority of them
cross over in 38 different degree
programs and we've now identified those
38 we've looked at where are their
unique combinations for example in the
North country with Plymouth or between
Great Bay community colleges and and UNH
some of them are unique but all of them
if we can get the general education
requirements lined up plus clear
articulation of if you are in a major do
you need that accounting course or do
you need anatomy and physiology great
example Mark
um and we're now trying to take that 38
we've identified the first 12 that we're
going to be working through uh and we
hope to do that within the next year in
addition this bill kicked off a
partnership that and I'll give
Chancellor Rubenstein credit that it was
his idea that I reach out to Kristen
Miller who's uh a vice president for
academic Affairs the kind of equivalent
of a Provost in the community colleges
they meet every month all the Community
College uh provosts meet every month and
the system provosts you the usnh system
Provost meet every month every other
month we're now meeting together we're
meeting as a team to have conversations
not just about 15 30 in fact for the
most part Leslie and Kate have been
driving that but instead to talk about
how do we get faculty talking together
how do we get make sure that the
advising is is smooth and that we are
communicating that these Pathways exist
so we're really quite excited
um the 12 low-hanging fruit that have
been identified so far uh by Kate and
Leslie and and their work uh include
um business administration uh is big
bambs uh across the two and education
programs so those two are going to be
the tip of the spear nursing is actually
one of the largest degree programs and
probably has the most well-articulated
Pathways already uh that's on there
um as well just to let you know and then
the last thing I'll say is working
together the the Provost and the vice
presidents for academic Affairs are
planning to report to our boards what we
are doing so at the end of June uh the
seven uh let's see the seven Community
College Provost and the three Community
usnh Provost are all going to the usnh
Border trustees meeting we're all going
to be there for Kate and Leslie to
present an update to those to that board
on what we're doing and in July we're
doing the same thing we're all going to
go to the community college board and
we're all going to present because it's
yes it's important to get the pathways
created yes it's important that we have
these clear articulations for our
students so that it's very clear what
path they can go on and that they can
change after they matriculate but it's
even more important that we'd be working
together so our faculty are talking to
one another so our advisors are talking
together and and that I think is going
to be that secondary success that's
going to make everything work
Mark what would you add
if I can take a little license to also
loop back to the previous question there
just tie some things together
um
start with an early college then doing
concurrent enrollment activity and the
question about whether it should take
four years although there are examples
of students actually finishing the
associate degree in the time that it
takes to complete High School the
typical student who's taking running
start courses with us is taking one or
two courses maybe taking some advanced
placement courses as well but it's it's
limited engagement at that point so From
perspective of a student who would
enroll at a four-year institution
whether it's Plymouth or or UNH or Keen
or whether it's
heaven forbid Boston University as a
full-time student they may take 12 or 15
or 18 credits a semester the cost is no
different and so that student can make
up the one or two courses they've taken
through early college and it sort of
disappears what we're hoping to do with
the investment that the state has
proposed for expanding dual and
concurrent enrollment and tying it to
1530 we'd actually like to build
structure to these Pathways so that a
student can take a meaningful set of
courses a coherent set of courses so
even beginning for students who are
academically qualified as early as the
sophomore year but certainly in the
Junior and Senior year a student would
have a semester or a year or more of
college as the foundation and we think
it does two things one from an
affordability perspective that's a year
less of tuition that they have to pay to
any one of us but it's also a year
sooner to get to the labor market for
students who have bad ambition to begin
to earn instead of paying into education
but the another thing we hope that we
can do in structuring this well
we know that New Hampshire has a
disproportionate share of college-bound
students going to four-year institutions
out of state we think that if we can
build these Pathways strongly enough we
can create an anchor that keeps more of
those students in New Hampshire because
they and their parents will see the
value proposition so part of what we're
hoping to do is actually build structure
not just the courses and the structure
of the pathways but activities around
the students who are enrolled in these
courses bring them to our campuses help
them see the opportunity to stay in New
Hampshire so affordability the return on
the investment for New Hampshire for
those students and their families is
significant
one of the questions that was asked
earlier but does this change the
economics of of the work we do and
absolutely it does in a couple of ways
between the two systems we'll no longer
expect to see two years or four years of
tuition from these students because
we'll have done more with the Early
College activities but one of the other
things the kinds of courses students are
most likely to take while they're in
running start or early college tend to
be general education liberal arts
business type courses what's going to be
left is an increasingly concentrated
portfolio of classes in clinical classes
technical classes that are more
expensive for us to offer without the
ability to subsidize if you will with
some of the larger enrolled general
education type courses so it will
increase the Reliance that we have on
the state to sustain affordability for
the state to continue to make investment
in that work the other piece that came
up was the question about degrees versus
alternative credentials
again it's a different it's a different
way of thinking about the economics of
post-secondary Education two or four
years of tuition is a relatively steady
Revenue stream from students micro
credentials among those twenty thousand
those could have been weekend classes
you know you know afternoon seminars or
or something larger than that but the
revenue is not the same as credit
courses and right now the federal
government doesn't treat them the same
so the availability of funding to
support that is going to change the work
whether a student rushes directly to
finish a two or four year degree
maybe comes maybe becomes less important
I think it was governor of Pennsylvania
who on his first day in office removed
the requirement of a bachelor's degree
for employment in the state of
Pennsylvania others have have done
similar things at a certain level that
degree becomes less important than the
education that supports it and the
specialized knowledge you know whether
it's in any particular technical field
what we really have to do better K
through 12 or pre-k through 12 we've got
to Foster literacy and numeracy we've
got to strengthen students critical
thinking we've got to foster a passion
for learning that doesn't get
extinguished by what they experience
because ultimately what we teach them in
any class or in any program is going to
have a limited shelf life what people
will need to learn 10 years now 20 years
from now and the workforce is likely to
be different so we've got to rethink the
way that our work as Educators it's not
the two years or four years after high
school even for those non-traditional
students it is going to be a light it's
legitimately lifelong learning that
responds to changes in technology the
economy people's lives and circumstances
one of the interesting data points in
New Hampshire employment economic
economic and labor market information
Bureau 2030 projections for occupations
over 700 occupations listed the
projection is that the workforce will be
000 people employed here in New
Hampshire
and it's not evenly distributed you know
a thousand people in each of those 700
plus occupations 58 of those occupation
no I shouldn't say 58 of the people
expected to be employed will be in roles
that don't require a specific degree
not not graduate degree not
undergraduate degree is going to require
some type of learning that's unique to
that responsibility to that role so
again as much as we focus on certain
occupations certain technical things and
there's no shortage there's going to be
a growth in a number of people who will
need bachelor's degrees or associate
degrees or doctoral degrees in certain
Fields but they will still represent
less than half of the people working in
the state who will need some type of
knowledge that they get from either
on-the-job training or short-term
training that prepares them to do what
they need to do next and we we've got to
be prepared to be responsive to those
changes
I'm I'm assuming thank you I'm assuming
that this is you're referring in large
part to the badges and that that whole
uh group of uh courses that may or may
not be developed around the badging
system that a lot of Industry seems to
be moving towards I I don't know that
there'll be Badges and personal care
assistant is going to be a steady demand
as we age as a population no specific
badge that I know although someone may
create one but it probably will require
a certain amount of knowledge
understanding of of psychology or
behavior of of Health you know so again
you can turn it into a badge or a micro
credential but people will need to know
what they need to know yeah
I would I would add that employers are
parked in the same space the the demand
for Badges and micro credentials is
coming less from employers and more from
the individuals that are doing the work
to pick up those skills uh when we
partner through professional development
and training we partner with companies
to deliver content to their employees
not to get a degree not to get credit
but to get the skill I the employers
want them to take it they don't care how
it gets curated
um so I think that that's going to be
something that the market is going to
figure out over time but it's coming
from the people doing the work to take
those additional trainings so they can
put it on their resume in a manner that
they have for Mark because also
applicable I think to the four-year
system uh are if I take a course at
White Mountain
is that going to be
recede by another Community College one
of the other six colleges or are they
going to in their own Department say
that doesn't measure up to what we have
as the criteria for that course how's
this working the same type of issue for
four year two that's exactly the work
that we've been undertaking to have
faculty across disciplines across our
system take a look at the curriculum we
offer in order to ensure that students
don't run into barriers that they will
know that this course is applicable at
other campuses across the system soon
virtually anything you would anticipate
comes in as a transfer course but we're
working to make it more seamless than
that historically we've had a hard time
just between keen and Plymouth yeah much
less the community college system and
this is it there's no reason for it at
all it's completely unnecessary it's
built on the culture of you know where
people are and what they're used to and
their sense of we know what's best for
our students and I appreciate that and I
value what you know their expertise but
I that that is an impediment to what our
students need so we are now working
across usnh but also with ccsnh
precisely so this stuff is clear and
unambiguous and so Nate if I'm applying
to UNH and I I've got the application
where if UNH feels or the university
system says it might be a good candidate
for Keen or a Plymouth but you're not
going to make it into UNH so I go to una
to Plymouth or to Keen I take a course
or two and decide I really want to move
back into UNH where I first want to go
are those courses that I now took at
Plymouth or Keene going to transfer to
you Wayne at the
historically the answer would have been
it's not up to Wayne it's not up to me
it's up to the faculty in whatever
Department it was to make that decision
and that is not the way no I'm telling
you the truth and that is not acceptable
and so what we really need to do is say
we and now we are in a place and we want
to be in a place across the state in
higher education to say absolutely no
question when are we going to get there
we're on the way so in some places we're
already there the question is how do we
do that more broadly
yeah that's I I wouldn't want you to
come away thinking we're not there
because we are in in many disciplines uh
particularly in the professional
disciplines in The Sciences in
engineering programs in uh in business
those transfer really really well where
we have some of our biggest problems is
actually in the liberal arts and the
humanities and we have to get those
faculty to communicate with one another
so that
we don't have this isolationist tendency
that has existed in higher education for
decades uh that is really the barrier
we're pushing against so do you have a
comment
Walter Peterson and I worked on
articulation agreements for years
we thought we had the problem solved
obviously the problem The Beat Goes On
but let me just say the hours that we
spent
on that situation talking to kids who
couldn't get their credits transferred
they you know it was
it was a terrible problem that it it it
it's really that's something that should
have been taken care of years years ago
uh we you're all accredited
you go through an accreditation process
that cost you a ton of money
right everybody gets the stamp of
approval used to be from the New England
board now it's but itchy
I went through it when I was president
of a college it's a real pain of the
neck but you all get it and it seems to
be why is it that the standard if they
get it why aren't the credits
transferable and it's it's been a
problem forever uh and it's really gonna
be it's got to be solved if it makes you
feel any better you were successful the
credits all transfer are great that the
credits transfer right into specific
challenges and this is true Community
College to usnh as well as between us
and H institutions is for some of the
majors and for some of those some of
[Music]
credits transfer what we'll work on now
actually is to have grades transfer as
well we want this to be seamless to the
point that a student can take the
courses they need where they need them
and part of this and it goes back to the
non-traditional question and the 1530
right now we have students and across
our system roughly 25 percent of our
instruction is occurring online
primarily through asynchronous online
instruction particularly for
non-traditional students who are
location bound the ability to take
advantage of a course that's offered at
another campus or being offered in the
semester they need it in the format that
they need it shouldn't be a barrier to
that student making progress so again
we're trying to make full use of what's
in 1530 not just thinking in terms of
two plus two but the language in that
bill is optimizing the utility and
affordability of the campuses and for
our non-traditional students who are
location bound both within the system
and between the two systems trying to
find ways to make full use of that
this has been very instructive I
appreciate your talking about this and
you talk about the multiple ways you're
serving students
but students equal economics
to each Institution
so with this multiple options
of um the My the micro certifications uh
going in going out competition between
schools
between let's say do I go to Plymouth do
I go to Keene do I go to UNH
it all boils down to some economics I
mean you've got your budget you've got
to deal with
so with the multiple approaches
of students gaining their education or
professional development opportunities
with business
I think ultimately
we can't each of us is a distinct
institution with a distinct Mission and
the strengths but we each of us cannot
be everything to every student and
that's not responsible that's not smart
it's not good for any of us so what
we're really committed to doing and one
of the reasons we're working as closely
together with the Arts okay so what do
we do really well at Plymouth what do
our students need how do we Define our
mission and articulate what we do really
well make sure we're not stepping on
anyone else's toes let them do I'm not
going to compete with an R1 that's that
doesn't make any sense for me it's not
going to serve my students well so Wayne
and I are going to work together to make
sure we understand our spaces and our
students and how we serve them and
ultimately that's not I mean not every
student belongs at Plymouth State and
not every student belongs at UNH and
that's the work that we need to do
together not every student needs to be
in a four-year degree and that's why we
have to be talking to each other but the
Kings music program can compete with UNH
oh yes and so somehow we've got
you know we've got to get this thing
well squared away here we have just
folded our Bachelor's in music degree
because we cannot compete with Keen and
we don't want to so we have a music Ed
degree that's very well used and highly
productive and we leverage it it's
important for the North Country we don't
need a bachelor of musical arts degree
at Plymouth State and we've closed it
down
it's worth sharing
so first of all I can't say thank you
enough for the partnership that we have
between the presidents the three
presidents at the three U.S NH
institutions and the Provost at the
three U.S Nation institutions are all
communicating constantly now and we're
making decisions collectively and we're
changing policies collectively to try
and make that a tighter integration that
was a great example Nate but it happens
at UNH as well I mean our athletic
training program at UNH I shut down
because it was higher rated at Plymouth
and so I'm going to shut it down I'm
going to partner with Plymouth because
we still have some students that want to
do that but they can do that in
partnership with a with a Plymouth
degree but we we have to go further than
that as we work together we have to take
a look at admissions because students
don't know that we need to be totally
comfortable with and we have been
students that apply to UNH and don't get
in are immediately made available to
Keenan Plymouth we have a wait list as
soon as we release the wait list we
release the waitlist to Keene and
Plymouth we have partnership that says
that you know for example at this time
of year what's going on right now
particularly this year in higher
education is hand-to-hand combat for
students that are either undecided or on
on somebody else's wait lists so we're
having more institutions so for example
the six New England flagships every one
of them went to their wait list this
year and their wait list is populated by
students at other so we're we're
literally fighting over individual
students but Keen Plymouth and UNH made
the Strategic decision to share our
lists so if I have someone that we're
going after that I know has already said
yes to Plymouth I'm not going after them
they're off limits and I think those
types of Partnerships those types of
policies and then the coordination of
our curriculum is what we need to do in
a state the size of New Hampshire in a
representative Ford
thank you and that sounds very
encouraging to hear that
one concern that bothers me in
particular and I don't like to get into
specific nitty-gritty but this is
General enough
a student presented a credential from
one another University and was asked for
the in addition to the credential itself
the curriculum of this course they took
to ascertain whether or not the
objectives of the course they were
trying to transfer match the objectives
at another institution which is not part
of what I have always understood
accreditation to be about
well this is unfortunately and you're
absolutely right this is what I was
referring to earlier that we have to and
and we are moving past historically the
control of what is taught is in control
of the faculty the substance and what
you're referring to is the syllabus of
the course has to be approved by the
department accepting the students now I
agree that is not the right way to be
doing it but historically and this is
tied to accreditation because the
ultimate academic decisions are made by
the faculty and the faculty on the
program so this is this is a complicated
this is tied to a creditor so they we
are accredited but it's complex so we're
working on this and we've made lots and
lots of progress to avoid exactly that
circumstance
accreditation might be at risk well
there's it depends on what you're
talking about as accreditation so
there's there's University accreditation
which is neche and then there's degree
accreditation so not knowing the details
of this specific regular case if the
degree if a course is transferring in
from I'll pick on abet which is the
engineering accreditor we are accredited
by abet if it's coming in from an abet
accredited institution it should
transfer
however the same course might be taught
at a non-abet accredited institution and
therefore they would need to to maintain
our abet certification look at the
syllabus what brought a particular twist
to the individual I'm talking about was
the course had been taken 11 years ago
uh
that's a good well we're really uh at
the time for closing this meeting down
and I want to thank you very much all of
you coming in from community college
system in the University system is it
possible that those reports which you're
going to be issuing to the trustees at
the end of June and on in July a copy of
that report could be issued to this
committee so we could share it with all
members on on the committee here
absolutely so that the what's going to
be shared with the boards of Trustees I
haven't seen it yet we're actually
meeting on the 12th to review it
um is going to be a slide that we will
definitely share that we were going to
share the slide deck plus a written two
or three page Report with the uh with
his body
um in August was our plan
okay
thank you
anything else from the committee right
now once again thank you very much this
has been an informative meeting and I'm
sure it opens up you know
part of it yeah supposedly
[Music]
you know say that it's being done by